Be careful.
Amazing.
It moves!
The direction is done based on
the drawings and timesheet done by the animators.
Like, we want this scene or this cut to have a certain atmosphere,
and we give instructions and direct it.
Based on the instructions,
the Chief Animation Director, that is,
the person who directs the movement of the character in the drawing,
will do the correction.
In some cases, we'll do a retake,
and ask the animator in charge, who drew the picture, to draw it again.
After that, depending on the anime or the workplace,
the Chief Animation Producer,
which is me in this case,
will check for consistency of characters,
like the facial expression, which must be consistent.
I also give them suggestions on how to draw something,
and I would draw it out and make corrections.
The above has been the work process of layout and rough draft.
After this, the drawings with added corrections
are returned to the animator in charge, who drew the layout.
The contents that have been corrected will be reflected,
and it'll be made into a clear copy, like a proper,
clean drawing copy.
It's the work process of the key animation.
When we draw a person punching someone in the key animation,
for example, we have the drawing of his arm pulled back,
this drawing of him starting to jab,
and the drawing with the arm extended, which are included in our key animation.
If it's only these three, it'd really be…
It would go quickly,
or the movement will become stiff with pauses like this,
so we need drawings in between.
The instruction is made into timesheets.
We must fill in the blanks between clean copies of key animation drawings,
done by adding drawings in between. That's the process of animation.
By the way, the number of pages of this animation drawings is 22.
We have 17 pages of key animation drawings.
We've added drawings in between in the animation and made it into 22 pages.
So five pages were inserted in between in the animation.
After this process, we check it on an actual screen all together.
If we get an okay, then the process of this cut is complete.
This is the timesheet and the key animation.
You'll wonder what it is, if it's just this.
This is also a rough draft.
It's drawn quite roughly.
This will do.
Camera work is added and it's filmed as a trial run.
This is the key animation.
It's the background art.
Combining them, it becomes like this.
This is only in an instant, too.
There's a lot in the filming part already.
So it's seven and a third.
Each character is different,
but it's basically about 3.5 till it reaches his crotch.
That's where the crotch is.
The upper body is about 3.5 heads long.
It's a bit late to say this,
but this is used as a rough guide.
Especially when we draw it this time,
we aren't drawing it as a job of a pro animator,
so I don't think we need to match it so strictly.
This is the protagonist, a character called Edamame, who is a swindler.
He can't fight, and he is weak,
so he is thin and has a slender figure.
He has sloping shoulders, and his shoulders are narrow.
This is Edamame's characteristic.
It's very important.
In terms of figure, she's slim.
All the characters we've seen are slim.
They're Yoshiyuki Sadamoto-san's characters,
so they're all slim, like Evangelions.
Now, we'll have a look at Twitter from the director's computer.
All the problems have been solved, so let's start.
Please start, Kato-san.
Kato-san, please have a look.
As I thought, some people couldn't finish in time.
Yeah.
It was 45 minutes. If there'd been 60…
Impressive.
It's impressive.
Yeah.
It's the chest of Edamame? Let's have a look.
- Only his chest is shown.
- Amazing. The person is skilled.
Right? It's fully colored, too.
How did they draw the playing cards, too? They're drawn, right?
Amazing.
Edamame has a defiant look on his face, it's like him and it's nice.
As what animators call it, it's something like image process.
It has light shining from above.
It's very beautiful.
Excuse me… We've scrolled through it.
The first… Well, not the first… After…
This… It moves!
A moving one.
Wow!
After she stretched and dash.
They said they didn't make it in time.
But I'm impressed that they made it move.
Maybe we could've asked them to make something that moves.
It's also a thick coating one.
The color of the contour line changes, it's pretty.
Some parts of the camera work have been blurred as well.
Each person made various effort. I keep repeating myself.
He is handsome.
His eyes are just like Laurent's.
It has been a wonderful program. Thank you.
- Thank you.
This is the end of today's program.
- See you again.
- Again?
Again... Is this okay?
Please enjoy the next program.
- Looking forward to next time.
- Thank you.